[Musique]
les publicités pour les protections
périodiques ne vont jamais montré les
femmes ayant leurs règles
la publicité elle est là pour vendre des
produits donc elle va vendre du rêve
elle va vendre du bonheur et c'est vrai
que sur les protections périodiques ce
qu'elle vend c'est la liberté
ce qui fait enfin ce qui est l'origine
de toutes ces déconvenues d'un certain
nombre de jeunes femmes qui le jour où
elles ont leurs règles découvre que un
tampon c'est pas forcément un signal de
liberté
[Musique]
on ne voit que des images de femmes dans
la vie quotidienne ou alors sur une
plage en train de courir donc les règles
sont présentés comme un moment de
libération du corps les publicités de
nana ne montent sont dans les premières
à montrer justement le produit mais elle
montre le packaging du produit
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit la serviette
emballé dans un joli petit plastique
coloré au fond du sac à main mais on ne
va pas voir la serviette sur une culotte
comme ce qu'on peut voir après dans les
autres salles ans
[Musique]
alors la société américaine c'est une
société puritaine
c'est la société qui invente en fait le
tampon c'est un médecin généraliste
américain qui invente le premier tampon
hygiénique et en fait comme il n'est pas
imaginable que les femmes aillent
l'installer elle-même dans le vagin
c'est pour ça que il ajoute un
applicateur mais qui n'était pas prévu
au départ
et donc c'est un une problématique qui
court depuis le début du 20e siècle et
qui accompagne complètement la
médiatisation des protections
périodiques qui revient souvent dans les
souvenirs des femmes qui ont eu leurs
premières règles dans les années 60 70
c'est cette idée que l pensait vraiment
à une libération parce que la publicité
pour les protections périodiques vente
tellement un moment de bonheur et de
liberté que le moment où elle découvre
ce que c'est et bien finalement c'est
pas que du bonheur et que de la liberté
et il ya même des témoignages de deux
petits garçons qui disent nous on rêvait
d'avoir nos règles ça avait l'air
tellement sympa de pouvoir gambader
partout et de pouvoir être libre de
faire du sport parce que c'était le
message qui était véhiculée par par ce
discours publicitaire
[Musique]
tu es représentation publicitaire et les
évolué avec l'ensemble des
représentations qu'on voit circuler dans
la société
il me semble que sur ces dernières
années et sur la représentation du sang
menstruel elles sont complètement lié au
militantisme des féministes
d'aujourd'hui qui ont représenté ce sang
menstruel dans l'espace public
le mouvement féministe aujourd'hui
utilisent vraiment les médias et les
nouveaux médias en particulier les
réseaux sociaux et je pense qu'on voit
les répercussions de ce militantisme
dans l'évolution du langage publicitaire
mais aussi fictionnel mais aussi dans
l'ensemble de la société